she was identified via fingerprints but
her I'm the person who found Marisela
and so you found I found her Wow
she was identified her body was in bad
wasn't it was in a bad state of decomp
they were able to get fingerprints to
match to her family had filed a
missing-persons report
but her body was so decomposed that they
had to remove her hands and then and
then put them in saline solution so they
could rehydrate them then to take them
to take the fingerprints oh my gosh
here's one story about Marisela and
about her family and about all the
people that have been deeply impacted by
her death that's just one verse heggs
yeah of one human human so you amplify
that story 3,000 times you know it's a
lot of it's a lot of sorrow especially
for the orange tags I mean there's
there's over a thousand people in
Arizona that have disappeared basically
the families alone that will never
probably find out what happened to them
and you know that's this horrible aspect
to it the desert is used as a way to
deter migrants and it kills them and
then it destroys their bodies
the goal is project I mean it is it's
participatory so these tags on this wall
were filled out by about 500 volunteers
at the University of Pennsylvania
several months ago and so with every
exhibition that we're doing in a hundred
and fifty locations on five continents
next year we send in the kits with the
basics and the information and then they
have to mobilize their communities to
fill out the toe tags and so for us the
most important aspect of the whole thing
is the filling out of the tags that kind
of moment of solidarity with with
migrants in them and then mounting it on
the wall so that's for us is that you
know so it's not just coming and looking
at the toe tag but it's but it's what
does it mean to write down someone's
name and the date they were found and
the
found in is that a way to raise our
awareness and connect us more of that
issue